is it still
true that in jacksonville you can't
perform yeah man they don't even let
if i go out there right now they're
going blitz police on blitzing so the
cops are just on your head out there
i ain't worried about no [ __ ] no
people no no i ain't worried about none
of that
it's the police yeah yeah nah for sure
man
man i'm police a kid i mean look i
you know when it comes to just like
the cops and you know we've seen so many
examples of like you know
they're out for for rappers right i mean
i mean look at you look at what happened
with pooh scheisse they i don't know if
you heard but they
they match the dollar bill from his
instagram the serial number on the
dollar bill
to the scene of a shooting where the the
money came out the truck
they literally took a picture from
instagram and they lined up the serial
number
from the bills like that [ __ ] isn't he
hit but bro that [ __ ] that [ __ ]
that's the kind of [ __ ] they're doing
mm-hmm so you got to be really careful
these [ __ ] ain't playing bro i
be out the way
i'm not the wait so you don't even live
in jacksonville at this point no i moved
i've been moving jacksonville they've
been made me move from out of there
that's good that's and that's and it's
so crazy now i look back on it see like
like i said
mature so i'm me growing up i look back
and i say
see there's a reason they got me from
out of there it's a good thing because
who would tend to probably be dead in
jail right now that's fair
because the way the type person i'm is
that like
i can move by myself like i'm type
person like
if they want to came here i would've
just came by myself right i think the
last time i saw you you
you weren't real deep i think you may
have one one two people with you what
i'm saying i don't even beat you and
that that
that might look that's my liberal you
got your family with you yeah that's my
little brother yeah he's still high
school i just want to show him
l.a what i'm saying i've been wanting to
show him like different stuff like
and i don't be like karen i can't even
watch many people like that i can't
watch a thousand people around
right right most people do it for the
look